I had something with me that said if all 18 to 25 year olds voted,
then you're sure, you're gonna be sure
that the politicians will have policy that affects you
because you now matter to them in that sense.
So that's why, you know,
voting and going out there and having your voice heard means that your,
your issues will be heard.
Um, because the politicians are now listening
because you're the voters and,
and you matter to them. Yeah,
we have lots of evidence that politicians listen to older voters
more than they listen to younger people.
And that is basically
because older people are more likely to vote than younger people.
Uh, so if young people want their voices to be heard,
then it's just so important to go out there and vote
and that, you know,
that is the, the main way, uh,
you can get your advice guaranteed to be heard in the political system.
And politicians will pay attention to the ballot box
more than anything else. Uh,
so, yeah, always,
always use that vote. If,
whenever you're able to vote,
make sure you, you go and vote.